eccoti ciao ciccio ecco esatto speck e
ti devo spiegare bene lo vedi questo
sangue per terra vedi che c'è gente
morta lì ecco la prima noi siamo quelli
che negli horror rappresenta negli
horror mo reggenze ecco noi siamo quelli
che puliscono qui devi pulire è capito
occhio che ti si sporca il moggio quello
degli strizzare veloce strizza è bella
domanda mese ci dovrebbero essere dei
secchi da qualche parte con l'acqua ma
lo vado a prendere massima che è un
gioco bellino alla conoscenza
ecco la ragione secchio dell'acqua slash
matic sarà quest aspetto che vendevano
figure no ha spiegato sporca cava eccolo
però devi prendere non siamo forti della
roba su quella rotella teese vinci le
mani allora questo è un secchio ok
questo su paci cose ecco adesso pulisci
bahrain brucia qua
eccovene adesso andiamo a pulire le cose
acquisto e ci mi sa che c'è un radar di
chi dice dove il sangue è ovvio che se
vestisse anche lo sci e impronte si
faccia dello strettissimo state prendo
il vecchio lo porto qualche non ci
mostra raccontami la tua vita di come
sei arrivato a questo mamma si è
amarezza ma stiamo scherzando
ha fatto scelte sbagliate durante il
liceo degli horror che devo diventare
cose lander meno questo è niente
ho già morto ciò è morto con una lettera
ai fini tende la devo a last one left
c'è proprio la storia di dietro ci crede
arca vacca mi serve un po di secchi un
pulito e sporcato di tutto deserto
perché no no no no devi metterci anche a
un altro punto per terra ma spreco di
secco no parco schifo
marco dio oddio questo successo sono
volato fortissima eco pulisci ma
lasciami stare là davanti cosa sto
vedendo no ma dai ma pure tu ma porca
vacca
se faccio io lascia stare fai fare a me
senza fare i pirla vieni qua quasi molla
ok
ma ecco tasca no non a me
aspetti pulisco aia finisco io avrebbe
ottenuto la nominato viene qua le
sfoglie di turisti che casino quanto
saranno genoa diciamo così che amiamo
papa quindi farvi capire questa mano
questo ciò che si tratta di di pulire
per terra 3d cento delle mamme
esatto andiamo a dare evolutionary robot
6 ma poi c'è un morto che si sta limando
il terreno se guardi si muove la testa
continua di moratti a questo è successo
qua ci sono degli arti
abbiamo pulito a qua c'è un altro
cadavere aspetto aspettare anche qua è
però servirebbe secco era un secchio ma
perché poi bisogna raccogliere pure gli
oggetti per terra
marco se devi pulire tutto deve brillare
ci puoi man ci devi mangiare per terra
dai sentirmi un po cresco l'hai fatto
per finire a fa questo lavoro qua ho
fatto l'accoglienza turistica il
turistico alberghiero jessica alba
cetara e cosa ha fatto per arrivare
significato c'è tutta youtuber
famosissima pulitore non monetizzato più
da ciccio alzavo più niente niente che
vuoi tu scherzi ma sta già occupando non
è monetizzato per niente perché il piano
di cioè che youtube adesso cosa c'è
sangue robe del genere non monetizzi più
nulla
e ovvio che si chiama viscera ed è pieno
di sangue pavimenti anche nella
copertina quindi il suo video co
monetizza devo pagare io youtube
permette a ragazzino monetizza una sega
però comunque video di 10 minuti per
trustee questo che cos'è ma c'è anche il
sangue dei robot maledetti androidi
facciamo ma le mamme e quindi me finché
sacrificio mangiato tutto così semplice
come siciliane se mi parli che si
capisca la parola studenti prova faranno
una siciliana io non parlando siciliano
aspetta ming a mio figlio
non so cosa dire mente metti incinta e
le ragazze a questo dicono le mamme
siciliano dice che quello di questo ma
come che discorso è
qua c'è da modo di mettere in cda
all'età di vent'anni come ci sono deve
dire qualcosa no tranquillo che non sono
di quelli che fate le famiglie molto
presto in sicilia capi si diverte io
dovrei dovrei già essere nonno ma se ho
23 anni dovrei avere già una stirpe una
dinastia le stesse l'uomo di casa è
chiusa il lille ieri in piede nella
fossa ciaia di tre anni ci sono tanti e
stai morendo ma se che adesso al prezzo
di più mia mamma quando mi dicevano non
sporcare occhio che sei rimbalzano degli
arti per terra fanno le chiazze di
salame però se magari non li trascinare
per terra cosa di ciccio porca vacca
ora come l'hai lasciato tra l'altro ma
cosa sto vedendo va bene allora qua è
fatto bisogna mettere i corpi in un
container capito che non guardi con il
successo non sono stato io non sono
stato il retour au dostal no week
cattivo che cosa hai fatto non si fa
cattivo to the kid ha fatto crescere
strong e tu che guardi
abbiamo tumori si e non ti dico come ho
visto come ti ho visto che che sei
uscito dal gergo sei diventato un
cadavere e stato bellissimo timore che
volevo fare questa colpa ne è valsa la
pena la donna che bordello hai fatto ma
manco col ciclo ciccio ma porca vacca
orali che che schifo in terra non
sporcare stai fermo scusa scooter lavora
e di gesù cos'è questa se la radio poi a
via alla rai aspetta a minacciamo subito
a loro mi piace stare a casa
sono morto come se morto mi hai tirato
la radio in faccia sono ma per agevolare
tirata la lav in faccia sono morto è
stato la è stata illuminante questa casa
prova di nuovo no ciccio madonna
no niente semplicemente messo il mouse
giudizio lo è con che togli parlamento
stimolavano stato deve dare un'occhiata
lila vedere come è emerso il posto che
schifo cosa ci hanno fatto qua eh la
madonna che schifo fasto posto qui ma
quadri e vabbè ace l'inceneritore ciccio
possiamo usare questo per buttarci
chorfi c'e problema è che c'è veramente
tanto schifo va certamente molto più
schifo di quanto bene ho trovato una
cosa interessante
che cos'è non lo so a da fuoco alle cose
che ho fatto più danno che altro
l'ho preso in una porno non so che cosa
diavolo si sa cosa serve però che ci
sono dei proietti permesso concesso nel
cesso o tienici ci guarda
ecco pillola blu dalla rossa blu e
prendi ok
chissà che avrà proprio una fisica
completa il gioco però ci sono dei pezzi
di alieno e pezzi di umano aspettava da
può dire cosa nel cesso comunque
simpatico sto gioco me lo ricordavo
dov'ero
siamo a dovremmo essere in 26 un'equipe
di 20 persone così li vede questa roba
non puoi farla nostra cos'è sta roba
immagini immaginate così mentre rap ma
mi sa che c'è un po di troppe robe per
terra poi c'è la scopre la scopa fa
qualcosa della mamma mia quanto grosso
suv si va beh ma questa qua fino a
domani quanta roccia il metal gear da
pulire
se te lo giuro quali sono i metalli ha
però da barozze attention swipe york
arden pool del cramt ma oggi siamo
tornati davanti all anno a sono
licenziati hanno sbagliato ho cliccato
sulla roba termina programma porca vacca
quasi amore nel nostro centro giudizi e
che è molto sfruttato adesso posso fare
un'altra mappa porca vacca vela proviamo
la nato ancora madonna di dio cosa vedo
chi c'è stato traffico se già entrato
già fatto bordello ma è pulisci ricava
da vedere se ci sono dei secchi in giro
porca vacca qua c'è un male però non
sarà entrare to vedere che succede
io non lo farò aspetta che devo proprio
buttare una bomba all'interno di stanze
ecco quanto è chiaro se mangiato la
bomba ed è uscito un cadavere
ok exclusive rendere quindi sotto
mentite bombe dentro il mostro non si
fanno niente niente
no non esploda aspetta ecco qua storage
keith gough 1795 ok 1795 e voilà styler
ciando tutto all'inizio ma spiegami che
mostri chi chi ha fatto questo
poi c'è un altro mostro ok c'è un'altra
porta orca vecchio quante cose che male
per me ma cosa per c'eravamo quasi come
dai va beh direi che possiamo concludere
qua dopo tutto sto bordello ragazzi
spero che vige la clean up ci sia
piaciuto cose se vivete lo sento mi
piace anche a stagione descrizioni ha
lasciato lasciti momenti anche il cane
di ciccio e qua c'è volevo li volevo
salutarti con delle gambe
ragazza comunque grazie prego benz cars
[Musica]